-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
And this is "Late Night."
How is everybody doing tonight
I'm not going to wait
to hear your answer
because I've got to
get to the news.
President Biden today delivere
the Commencement Address
at the U.S. Coast Guard Academy.
The Coast Guard has change
a lot since Biden was young,
but then again,
so have the coasts.
After House Minority Leade
Kevin McCarthy
came out in opposition yesterday
to a bipartisan agreement
to create
a 9/11-style commission
to investigate the January 6th
Capitol attack,
Democratic Caucus Chair
Hakeem Jeffries said, quote,
"I don't know what
Kevin McCarthy is afraid of.
Oh, if I was going to guess,
I'd say ghosts, spiders, clowns,
lightning, dogs, spicy food,
fireworks, and Donald Trump?
The House voted today
on legislation
to create
an independent commission
tasked with investigating
the January 6th attack
on the Capitol,
while House Republicans
are still claiming
that there was no January 6t
this year.
President Biden yesterday toured
Ford's electric vehicle facility
in advance of the company toda
unveiling its new truck,
the Lightning.
So just try peeing on this one
Calvin.
Several Republican lawmakers
on Tuesday
protested House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi's mask rules
on the floor
during a voting session.
And Representative Bryan Mas
said after
that the fine was the, quote
"best $500 I ever spent."
"Not me," said Matt Gaetz.
[ Laughter ]
"I got the Venmo receipt
to prove it."
The New York Attorney General'
office announced yesterday
they are, quote,
"actively investigating
the Trump Organization
in a criminal capacity."
"That's awful,"
said Ivanka Jones.
A strip club in Las Vegas
will begin offering coronaviru
vaccinations later this week
They'll have Moderna
and AstraZeneca,
but just know their real names
are Cynthia and Beth.
[ Laughter ]
A strip club in Las Vegas
will begin offering coronaviru
vaccinations this week.
Said dudes, "Am I crazy, o
did that nurse really like me?
A strip club in Las Vegas
will begin offering coronaviru
vaccinations later this week
But just remember, they can va
you, but you can't vax them.
The vacation rental compan
booking.com
will offer fans
of the sitcom "Friends"
a chance to win
an overnight stay
in a replica of Monica's
New York City apartment.
So if you've always wanted
to spend the night
at Monica's apartment,
just tell her, man.
Mattel yesterday unveiled
a Helen Keller Barbie doll
Still not as blind as Barbie
How can you not see it?
Do you really believe
those are business trips
he takes every weekend?
And finally,
a woman recently wrote
to the "Dear Prudence"
advice column
in "Slate" magazine
asking what to do about
finding her 12-year-old so
in a compromising position
with the vacuum cleaner.
Well, for starters,
change the bag.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like there's someon
on the West Coast
who's going to get it
in a second.
And that was a monologue.